let's click submit and then
there it is
[Music]
the moment couldn't be any better it's
important to have it
it's a very important contrast to what
you usually see
[Music]
yes
[Music]
and right at the base we have an
enslaved ancestor
followed by a union soldier who has been
lynched
and on top of that we have a protestant
woman with her baby at her back
the enslaved ancestor gives support to
the union soldier who also gives support
to the
next generation being the the mother who
is protesting
who is also supporting her her son
with the hopes that her protest will
create a brighter future for her
children
[Music]
everybody has a voice everybody has an
opinion and the statue is designed to
spark conversation
the artist kwame nakota bomfo created
the statue
to basically do that to start
conversation and it allows
the audience of the people who see the
statue to interact with it and say
whatever they want to say
whatever's on their mind or whatever the
statue makes them
it's particularly interesting for me and
significance to see a black woman
at the top of this monument because it
highlights the often ignored and often
forgotten
histories of black women within the
transnational struggles
for independence for equality amongst
other things
we don't have stuff like this in oregon
we don't have people talking about
what this country has done to black
people
and this piece really shows that it's
not holding anything back and i've
always felt that
people need to stop treading lightly
around this subject because what we have
done to black people in this country is
beyond horrific